a few question about the classical World
Championship that you're obviously not
playing I guess it's you know yeah I'm
I'm not playing the candidates don't
worry about that I would say the main
reason that I I'm not playing the
classical World Championship is that I
don't enjoy it it's as simple yeah it's
as simple as that I think under the
current format with the time control
that there is it's extremely unlikely
that I will compete in the classical
World
Championship I've had a great well 2
years now uh since I played the last
World
Championship I really don't really don't
miss it I really like the life that I
have now both playing from home but also
traveling playing tournaments and um
yeah I simply simply don't need it what
would it have to look like what would
the format need to be for you to
consider going
back I think if you reduced time
controls made it more games that would
be a very good
start what should sort of be the thing
that establishes the number one player
in the world what kind of competition
could it be I think the number one
player in the world needs to be good at
everything really uh at
all at all formats obviously the rating
system usually lags a bit behind but if
you look at if you like look at that
over time that's a pretty good um
indication of um who are the
uh who are the best players and also
like if you want to know who the best
player is you don't have to look at all
the different formats and so on you can
just look for my name that's was a good
way to do it so what is it that keeps
motivating you when you have achieved
basically everything well I do like to
play chess uh so that motivates me I
still enjoy the struggle I enjoy trying
to win I mean it's not it's not really a
question question for me motivation is
not it's not a problem for um for these
events obviously when I feel that I'm
doing well it's it's it's easier but um
right now I just feel like I've been in
in a fairly good place mentally for for
a while so it's it's not really a
problem at all but is there anything
left for you to accomplish in chess I
think there are always things that I can
do better when when I play uh but
uh I haven't thought too much about what
goals I want to achieve or anything uh I
just like to play I mean it's basically
as as simple as that yeah well how do
you want the world to remember Magnus
Carlson I want to play for a while still
so I don't want to be remembered anytime
soon looking back on your career what do
you now see as the Highlight is it a
long time ago is it quite recent I have
I have a lot of good memories from chess
one that I often talk about is the
Norwegian under 11 Championship back in
2000 which was really like the first big
uh kids tournament that I that I won I
would say apart from that you know
Triple Crown the first time was fun uh
vion 2013 uh when I posted my best score
score there that's a really good memory
cuz I was just
I don't know I was just really relaxed I
I was about to play the candidates
tournament so I didn't have any openings
to play or whatever but I was just not
preparing too much for the games just
having fun and and somehow that that
went really really well yeah I mean
there are a lot of lot of good memories
but I rarely like dwell on the moments
or the tournaments that go well I
usually just look look forward to the
next one what is your vision for the
game of chess going M forwards I do get
the chance in February to do something
that I've never done before and that
really hasn't been done before in chess
either which is to play Fish random
chess or freestyle chess as as it's
called in this tournament uh at the
classical time control I'm really
looking forward to uh to do that cuz
fish random chess I think it's always
been played in Rapid time control which
never made a lot of sense to me since
you have to think for move one then you
lead then you need more time to think
and for classical chess there's a lot of
theory so you would need less time so
it's better to play rapid and Blitz
there um instead and that's one of the
visions that I have for the future that
there will be more um f random chess or
other variants for classical and that
regular chess will be more rapid and
Blitz which I think it's better better
suited for classical time control for
fish random and other than that you
envision faster chess basically faster
chess is is the is the future how about
the fans how should they be involved
well obviously most chess fans watch
tournaments online or on
TV and I think that's the way it's going
to continue for for the foreseeable
future I do want to have events as well
that look more like chess boxing where
there are a lot of fans maybe the
players can play with um noise
cancelling headphones so that uh you
know people around can make as much
noise as they want so I do think that
that's something that could be be
exciting for for chess as well yeah I I
still think most of um the chess Fan
Experience is going to be be online but
there there are also ways like the fan
Zone in Toronto where you can you can
set up exciting possibilities also way
away from the um from the venue we
obviously have to talk a little bit
about cheating which has been a big
topic uh this last year um so what risk
do you think that U cheating is sort of
posing to the game of chess I think um
because engines are so much better at
humans uh cheating is it is sort of a
existential risk to to the game and I
think as as long as you have this
element which can sort of tell you the
both the score but also it can a lot of
the times just give you the right right
answer
um yeah that that is that is definitely
a
big um a big challenge in terms
of many people
cheat yeah I don't know um I think
between the very top players there's
still a
pretty um pretty good level of of trust
that people are are playing playing Fair
um but I know that at other other levels
the trust is considerably considerably
less and it it is frustrating for for
players to to have these thoughts in the
in the back of their minds that um yeah
if somebody you don't know suddenly
plays really well yeah it inevitably
Creeps in
I try not to think too much about um
what cheating is going on in title
Tuesday and other events I simply yeah I
simply don't know I think that chess is
doing doing quite uh well uh in general
U but uh I but I do think that cheating
is like even if if it's not that big a
problem right now and I'm not going like
to judge whether it is it is like I
think it it is like the existential
threat to to um to the game and it's
like and it doesn't really doesn't
really go go away I liked what was being
done in Toronto I think generally the
players felt really felt really safe
there and I know that tournament
organizers as well for over theboard
events are are
um doing doing better than they were uh
but um
yeah still it's always sort of in the
back of um back of your mind so what are
the most effective measures do you think
that organizers can do both OTB and and
online I think for
OTB I mean it's obvious but delays are
good random scans are are good and to me
it's it's a little bit like uh airport
security in the sense that you're not
going to catch everything but at least
you make the players feel safer by
having sort of a security presence and
what should the punishment be if you're
caught
cheating I think in terms of uh
punishment it depends on the severity
but um I think the reason why people
don't really cheat like among the elite
is that I think like if you're caught
you're just not going to be you're just
not going to be invited back I sort of
wouldn't
I mean this is like computer cheating of
course specifically um but yeah I
generally think that's the way it should
be that that you don't yeah you don't
get a lot lot of um lot of
chances so what role does um psychology
and like the psychological warfare play
in a chess game for you I think
psychology plays a um significant role
for sure um personally I know that
people I mean people play a little bit
differently against me than they do
against some others um maybe like a
little more passively a
little more apprehensively times even if
it's just even if it's uh subconscious I
think they yeah definitely when I play I
try to use the sort of psychological
advantages that I that I have especially
against players that I feel more likely
to um to be sort of be Bluff um I try
and like push them a bit harder other
players I might not not try that try
that with uh Bobby Fisher like famously
said that I don't believe in Psychology
in chess I believe in good moves and I
would say that I believe in both what
kind of psychology you can use against
your opponent I think opening
preparation is definitely part of the
psych psychological preparation from the
now from the world rapid and Blitz
Championship that that I played I played
the uh o Kelli Sicilian A6 some move to
against yuang I did the same against
Wesley in Toronto finals which uh a game
which I won and I did that specifically
against players whom I thought will not
have sort of a sufficiently aggressive
response to uh a provocation in the
opening how about creativity and
originality in your play I feel like I'm
winning games the same way that I was
even back in 2009 when I won the world
Blitz championship for the first time
it's all yeah it's a lot of lot of
endgame strength and putting pressure
like willing my way to to win so um I
don't put a lot of emphasis on
originality or or creativity for me
chess is chess is a sport um it's
about getting like maximizing the
chances of getting the results you want
and um in in that sense um you know
creativity is
not it's not high on my list of
priorities besides I don't think I'm a
very creative person to begin with like
I rarely like come up with completely
new ideas I'm more the sort of person
who you know picks up other ideas really
really
well yeah they used to they used to say
that about about an as well that um he
would always play every new idea uh the
second
time cuz he picked up new things very
very quickly uh but um he wouldn't
necessarily invent them himself how has
chess.com been as a partner for for your
vision chess.com has been has been
really good last um the last year it's
made my life um a bit easier since
things are um sort of more more
centralized they definitely have lot of
ideas and Visions for um for the future
and many of them correspond um pretty
well with uh with
mine in what ways is chesc sort of
helping to evolve the game do you think
I think ches.com has um has a great
reach um obviously and uh they're also
making the game faster and and more fun
is there you thinks you would like them
to do different l or things they could
do better I think there are always
things that can be uh done uh that done
better production wise and so on but uh
you know that's really not not my um my
area another thing though that I think
you know can be incorporated is um fancy
chess uh which I'm I've been been been
working on lately and uh we will have
fantasy chess now for title Tuesday
events this um uh this year and I think
for eventually for for a lot of other
tournaments as well so I think there
that's also some something that will
make also ches experience even better as
a big fantasy football player yourself
for those who don't play fantasy sports
what can they expect when they now get
to play Fantasy chess I think fantasy
chess will um uh you know it will bring
a different different element I think a
lot of people like to watch sports and
feel like they have a little bit on the
line and um if you play Fantasy chess
you will sort of root for your um pieces
or players uh to to perform so you will
have another another element um of of
excitement there and another another bit
of uh content what do you think about
the job feay is doing you know right now
one of the good things things uh about
not playing the World Championship um is
that I've sort of I sort of made sure
that I don't have to be part of those
discussions like it's not
really it's not really up to me to tell
F or whoever what to what to do um so I
think um they they do what they do but
it's for me it's I'm mostly like
independent of um of of that yeah but if
you were running feta what would you do
differently uh then something seriously
would have gone wrong with my life if I
were to
[Music]
run